[Musik]
kommen die Aliens Diskussionen um die
Sprengung der Pipeline und hat Berlin
eine neue Regierung verdient spannende
Gäste heute hier bei 8:15 Uhr ich freue
mich auf Robert Fleischer das Autor und
ufo-experte der die Bundesregierung dazu
aufruft sich wie viele andere
Regierungen weltweit intensiv mit
unbekannten Flugobjekten zu beschäftigen
er sagt wir stehen vor einem Erstkontakt
Kinder sollen sich nicht mehr als
Indianer verkleiden jetzt zur
Faschingszeit wieder ein großes Thema
Journalistin Krischke hatte zu ein Buch
geschrieben und warnt Walking es ist ein
Kampfbegriff geworden dann Spalte und er
noch Gräben vertiefe CDU-Politiker Lukas
Schal hat sensationell sein Wahlkreis in
Berlin Mitte gewonnen trotz einer klaren
Stimmen Mehrheit will die alte Koalition
aber weiter regieren Schall sagt die
Stadt die will kein weiter so sie will
endlich den Neuanfang die SPD müssen
sich bewegen für großes Aufsehen sorgte
der amerikanische investigative
journalist Zimmer Hirsch nach dessen
Recherchen die Nord Stream Deadline
angeblich von den USA gesprengt wurde
mein Kollege Karl Victor Wachs
widerspricht da vor fehlen einfach
Indizien und alle Diskussionen um die
Pipeline die nutzen nur Russland das den
Westen weiterspalten will zunächst aber
reden wir über eine Ereignis dass die
Deutschen ebenfalls stark polarisiert
der Ballett Choreograph Marco Goecke hat
wenig zimperlich auf einer harsche
Kritik an seinem neuesten Werk reagiert
während der Pause einer Premiere an der
Staatsoper Hannover beschmierte er die
fast kulturkritikerin Wiebke hüster mit
Hundekot im Gesicht die Kritikerin hatte
sein Stück als Verfahren und
unkonzentriert zerpflückt diese Attacke
auf eine Journalistin die verbreitete
sich weltweit wie ein Lauffeuer einige
forderten natürlich sofort den Rücktritt
des Choreografen einige andere zeigten
aber sogar Verständnis der sich Gurke
und Publikum sein Lebenswerk um seine
Tänzer die hart und intensiv gearbeitet
haben sorgte darüber sprechen wir jetzt
hier bei 8:15 Uhr sie sind selbst
Journalist haben sie Verständnis für
eine so extreme Form des Protests für
eine so extreme Reaktion auf Kritik nein
also darauf habe ich dafür habe ich kein
Verständnis es ist ja ihre Aufgabe der
Kollegin als Theaterkritikerin auch
entsprechend Kritik auch aufzuschreiben
und zu formulieren ich finde dennoch bei
allen stallvorlagen die diese Vorgang
natürlich diese ungeheuerlich
vorgegangen würde ich sagen schon auch
liefert hat er schon auch einen wahren
Kern insofern dass wir uns bis hier
gerade schon richtig im gesagt hatten
auch der Frage stellen müssen wie weit
kann Journalisten eigentlich gehen
dürfen Journalisten eigentlich gehen
jetzt unabhängig von diesem konkreten
Vorfall aber wenn wir uns auch in den
vergangenen Jahren erlebt im Rahmen der
Corona Debatte ganz ganz stark auch im
dass man schon das Gefühl hatte dass oft
sich Journalisten dann vom Schreibtisch
aus irgendwie für die gute Pointe dann
auf Kosten von anderen sich vielleicht
manchmal etwas mehr überlegen sollten
welche Konsequenzen das sind auch für
die einzelne Person haben könnte
wie bewertest du das ist klar ist jetzt
suspendiert zumindest in Hannover andere
halten an dem Fest glaubst du er wird
überhaupt die Chance haben jemals wieder
eine Bühne zu betreten also Patricia ich
habe auch darüber nachgedacht so was
System durch den Kopf gegangen der Mann
ist 50 Jahre alt als er diese Kacke ich
glaube das kann man so sagen der Dame
ins Gesicht geschmiert hat und ich
glaube dass er eigentlich ein Kunstwerk
damit selber setzen wollte irgendwie
eine eigene Form von Kunst sie haben
gesagt wie weit dürfen Journalisten
gehen eine eigene Form von Kunst
etablieren und ich glaube ein bisschen
feierte sich dafür natürlich ist das
großes Turbo er hat wahnsinnig viel
Kritik aber zwei oder drei Jahre später
mal sehen was die Leute dann sagen ob
sie nicht vielleicht sagen da war doch
ein guter Kniff dahinter zumindest
erinnert man sich wahrscheinlich in
diesen Namen in der wahrscheinlich
negativen aber man erinnert sich
natürlich an diesen Namen ähm zumindest
einige halten an dem Fest die
Stuttgarter Tanz
weiter mit ihm zusammenarbeiten der
Fleischer finden Sie man darf man sollte
vielleicht sogar so eine Attacke auch
verzeihen können
ja das finde ich es ist ja ein Künstler
er ist kritisiert worden er hat sein
ganzes Herzblut reingegeben in das Stück
ich meine abstraktes Theater abstraktes
vielleicht ist nicht jedermanns Sache ja
ähm aber ich denke schon dass man ihm
ist und ist auch schon ganz anderen
Leuten für ganz andere Sachen verziehen
würden
am Ende was er selbst dazu zu sagen hat
dann auch er hat sich geäußert jetzt
ich denke dass die die die Wahl der
Mittel
Blut und natürlich ist das
gesellschaftlich auch bestimmt nicht
anerkannt oder respektiert wenn man
solche zu solchen Mitteln greift und ich
bin auch ein Mensch der sowas gar nicht
noch nie gemacht hat
insofern bin ich natürlich auch ein
bisschen erschrocken über mich selber
und das war sicherlich nicht die Mittel
waren sicherlich nicht gut aber wenn man
natürlich in der Öffentlichkeit steht
und
mein Beruf mein Werk mein Geschäft
über Jahre auch durch so jemanden durch
seine Journalistin beschmutzt sieht und
dann gibt es halt auch immer nur die
Antwort ja das ist der Preis wenn man
eine Person des öffentlichen Lebens ist
aber da bin ich ab einem gewissen Punkt
bin ich da auch anderer Meinung
so wir haben also alle über ihn
gesprochen jetzt haben wir ihn auch hier
in der Runde gehört Herr Schaal haben
sie eine Entschuldigung rausgehört in
aus diesem Sätzen nein ich habe da keine
Entschuldigung rausgehört und ich sag
mal die Auseinandersetzungen auch um
Kunst und Kultur sollten doch im Bereich
des verbalen bleiben also jegliches
beschmieren oder festkleben an an Dingen
und Gegenständen wie wir das ja auch
hier in der Auseinandersetzung mit der
klimaprotestbewegung sehen sollte
unterlassen bleiben das wird uns in
unserer Demokratie nicht ja
sie sind ja auch JuristInnen jetzt also
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass das
natürlich eine Beleidigung darstellt und
da können schon ich weiß jetzt nicht ob
er Wiederholungstäter ist dazu müsste
man müsste man sich das anschauen das
hört sich ja so an als hätte er dass das
erste Mal gemacht insofern denke ich ist
er damit Geldstrafe wahrscheinlich
Geldstrafe und das war's nicht
unterschätzen das kam jetzt schon raus
so ein bisschen also es ist ja ein
Unterschied ob ich etwas sage das war
okay weil oder ob ich zu versuchen zu
erklären was jemand dazu bringt so ein
Schritt zu gehen vielleicht aus einem
komischen Impuls heraus weil ich mich
frage ob er das Tütchen plötzlich hat
aber das wird noch
t es wurde der offenbar Gassi geführt
hatte das entweder das weiß natürlich
niemand mit Plan in der Tasche oder so
in der Tasche das können wir hier
natürlich nicht klären aber so ist
glaube ich ist doch nicht der Punkt
was man aber schon gehört hat ist es ist
aus seiner aus seiner Antwort jetzt oder
aus dem Wasser gesagt hat diese diese
gewisse Machtlosigkeit die glaube ich
ähm unser einer vielleicht gar nicht so
richtig oft nachvollziehen kann weil wir
ja selbst die sind die die Plattformen
haben uns zu artikulieren um uns quasi
auch zu streiten und alles und wenn ich
natürlich jemand bin der wie er
zumindest angedeutet hat jetzt über ja
ich kann es nicht beurteilen ob das so
ist quasi immer wieder ein Verlust nach
dem anderen über sich lesen musste und
vielleicht ist ihm da jetzt einfach mal
die Schnur doch gegangen so ja das war
ein Kunstwerk an sich also ich finde ja
schade sie waren da ein bisschen spießig
ehrlich gesagt das ist doch lustig
machen glaube ich für die Frau die in
der Pause dann versuchte mit sich mit
Hilfe der Presse Dame vom Hundekot im
Gesicht es gibt keine schlechte und dies
jetzt die bekannteste ballettkritikerin
Deutschlands und das Ihre nächste Kritik
egal was sie schreibt wird gelesen
werden irgendwas bleibt immer hängen
erwachsen ich hoffe ihnen passiert das
nicht
wenn sie mal ein Artikel schreiben der
nicht allen gefällt das passiert öfter
wenn wenn wir hoffen wenn sie
hoffentlich nicht in der Bahn plötzlich
einfach Opfer einer solchen Attacke also
man muss da schon bei dem bleiben was
rechtlich geboten ist es wird ja auch
in der reinstecken können das ist glaube
ich das Thema dass du jetzt auch so ein
bisschen tangiert hast müssen da
Journalisten aus deiner Sicht einstecken
können jetzt abseits ist dieser Attacke
ich glaube da sind wir uns alle einig
weit über der Grenze war aber wo ist für
dich die ganze erstmal sagt ja das das
muss ich auch einstecken können wenn ich
das austeile also Patricia wir wissen
das beide wir arbeiten für eine
Boulevard Marke hier bei Bild
nicht den mächtigen vorzuhalten was die
falsch machen wir sind wir werden dafür
bezahlt Leute zu kritisieren und
natürlich werden die Küche will muss
auch die Hitze aushalten können wenn wir
dann zurück kritisiert werden dann ist
das ganz normal ehrlich gesagt wäre es
wahrscheinlich sogar schlecht wenn es
nicht so wäre ob Kacke im Gesicht sein
muss klar kann man machen kann man
vielleicht auch lieber lassen aber ich
finde eigentlich dass wir da durchaus
auch in der Bringschuld sind ein dickes
Fell zu haben
und wenn dann mal einer kommt und ich
versuche zu beschmieren
also wir wollen nicht hoffen dass das
ich glaube da sind wir uns auch einige
am Tisch das Teil keiner sich wünscht
das so etwas jemanden einem anderen
wieder fährt ein Thema das Deutschland
auf jeden Fall nicht loslässt kann man
sagen ebenso verläuft eine emotionale
Debatte Viktor und den amerikanischen
investigativ schnellsten Zimmer Hirsch
er hat jetzt auch im Interview mit der
Berliner Zeitung noch mal nachgelegt und
behauptet er hat eine Quelle die
beweisen soll dass die Sprengung der
Pipelines aus den USA mit Hilfe von
Norwegen haben du du hältst das aber für
eine gefährliche und unbelegte Theorie
die eigentlich der russischen Propaganda
noch in die Hände spielt ein Thema
die USA sind schon immer ein Verbündeter
von Deutschland die haben uns geholfen
im Kampf gegen den Kommunismus die
standen immer an unserer Seite und im
Rahmenwerk der NATO sind wir alliierte
vor dem Hintergrund ist doch völlig
quatschig anzunehmen dass die USA
ausgerechnet mit Norwegen zusammen als
Mittäter Nord Stream 1 und 2 gesprengt
haben aber genau das sagt Timo Hirsch
und wem tut er damit einen Gefallen
Russland und Wladimir Putin den
russischen Diktator und das ist doch
Quatsch je mehr Verdächtige es gibt und
je mehr Zwietracht durch solche Aussagen
gesehen wird dass du mehr Gefallen tun
wir Putin und deswegen dürfen wir dieser
Lüge nicht auf den Leim gehen
behauptet ja dass dieser Plan zur
Sprengung schon vor Kriegsbeginn quasi
existierte er führte eine PK von beiden
und Scholz auch ins Rennen und sagte er
sagte beiden auch man werde eben Mittel
und Wege finden es Nord Stream Probleme
zu lösen so wurde das Meer oder weniger
gesagt er wertet das als Indizes
auf dem diplomatischen Parkett werden
solche Sachen halt ab und zu mal gesagt
hört sich auf einer einzige Quelle eine
einzige Quelle die er nicht einmal
namentlich benennen kann allein da fängt
doch schon an wir haben zwei
quellenprinzip im Journalismus und wenn
wir nur eine Quelle haben dann brauchen
wir Dokumente die belegen dass das was
sie sagen war es er hat keine Dokumente
er hat keine zwei Quellen er hat
irgendwie berechnet welche Taucher da in
wie viel Meter Tiefe hätten operieren
können es hat alles hinten und vorne
nicht gestimmt also glaube ich nicht
gesehen Journalist wir stehen sie zu
solchen Recherchen von Hirsch
also ich glaube es ist erstmal
grundsätzlich gesund alle Dinge mal
kritisch zu hinterfragen und gerade wenn
man noch keine Antworten auf irgendein
bestimmte gewissen Vorgang hat zumindest
mal irgendwie mal über ein paar Theorien
nachzudenken aber was sie schon auch
richtig sagen also diese eine Quelle die
da irgendwie ihm das stecken soll er
sagt immer das sources oder so ähnlich
ähm da weiß ich auch nicht ehrlich
gesagt wie ich das bewerten soll
vielleicht wird die werden seine
Aussagen jetzt auch aktuell ein bisschen
sehr hoch gekocht dann ist natürlich
schon so dass es ein narrativ ist der
glaube ich einigen Leuten sehr zu Gute
kommt sage ich mir in dieser dieses Land
doch sehr auf geht's Debatte die wir da
gerade führen ich würde mir sowas
anhören ähm ich würde sowas immer mal
mitnehmen ich würde immer sowas
nachdenken auch egal wie alt der Herr
ist oder was auch immer der das sagt
aber ähm ja sich ich habe auch so ein
bisschen das Gefühl dass es nicht ganz
komischer und das Motive wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen sie gesagt zumindest
muss man sich alles einmal anhören und
auch mal bewerten macht das Motiv dass
er ins Ziel führt irgendwie Sinn oder
haben Sie eine Theorie dazu oder haben
Sie eigene Überlegungen dazu also wir
hatten relativ Anfang an natürlich uns
Gedanken darüber gemacht wer das hätte
sein können jetzt bin ich kein
Militärexperte ja also ich kann jetzt in
dem in dem Umfang nicht beurteilen wer
da jetzt was wie machen muss klar ist
glaube ich dass dass man über eine
gewisse technologische Möglichkeiten
verfügen muss das könnten aber
Unternehmen genauso sein wie starten was
ich glaube ich viel wichtiger finde an
dieser Debatte anstatt jetzt sozusagen
ohne Beweise ist irgendwelche Theorien
durchzukauen ist eher die Frage
der Sicherheit Infrastruktur und darüber
haben wir dann danach klappt auch sehr
viel mehr gemacht ja dass das
Infrastruktur teilweise schlecht
geschützt wird also jetzt mal ganz
salopp formuliert kann sie jetzt dort
und diese Partner einfach hintauchen und
ihnen passiert im Endeffekt nichts und
das ist glaube ich von dem Hintergrund
dieser vielfachen Bedrohungen die wir
haben auch aus aus ganz anderen
Bereichen wichtig uns darüber mal
Gedanken zu machen wo wir eigentlich
Infrastruktur nachmessen müssen gerade
bei wichtiger Infrastruktur wie geht's
Ihnen mit solchen Informationen wir
haben gerade hier am Tisch festgestellt
es ist wichtig verschiedenste
Informationen zu beleuchten jetzt stehen
wir hier vor der Frage es gibt nur eine
Quelle eine angebliche Quelle die wird
nicht offen gelegt es gibt nur
Spekulationen das werden wir hier an
diesem Tisch auch heute mit Sicherheit
auflösen können also ich gebe ihnen
erstmal recht es ist natürlich schlecht
wenn man halt Journalist nur eine Quelle
hat die dann auch noch anonym ist aber
dann ist das Simo Hirsch das muss man
sagen er hat in der Vergangenheit viele
große Enthüllung Stories gebracht und
Serie ist es also anzunehmen dass sie
vielleicht dann noch was kommt aber man
muss nicht 7 Uhr Hörsch sein ganz
ehrlich um zu sehen dass die Amerikaner
keine Lust auf Nord Stream 2 hatten und
das sagen die ja sogar selber ich möchte
sie kurz daran erinnern am 7 Dezember
sagt Victoria newtland wenn Russland in
der Ukraine einmarschiert wird Nord
Stream gestoppt
sagt der Senator im Ausschuss für
auswärtige Beziehungen ich hoffe dass
wir ein Gesetz auf den Weg bringen das
nordstream nicht nur ausgesetzt wird
sondern dauerhaft beendet wird am 7
Februar sagt dann Joe Biden in
Anwesenheit von Olaf Scholz diesen Satz
den sie vorhin erwähnt haben glauben sie
wir werden das tun sagt er auf die
Nachfrage der Journalist aber wie wollen
Sie denn das stoppen wenn doch
Deutschland die Chance hat oder die
Gewalt darüber hat ja
am 26 September fliegt dann Nord Stream
2 in die Luft am 30 September sagt der
US Außenminister das stellt jetzt eine
ungeheurige Gelegenheit da ein für alle
Mal die Abhängigkeit von Putins Energie
zu beenden und ähm und am 26 Januar sagt
Victoria newtland die US-Regierung ist
sehr erfreut zu wissen dass Nord Streams
war jetzt ein Klumpen Metall auf dem
Meeresgrund ist und ähm allein anhand
dieser Sachen muss ich sagen klingt das
für mich so wie die Amerikaner haben
gesagt sie haben kein Interesse darauf
sie haben gesagt sie werden zerstören
und es sieht so aus als hätten sie es
gemacht und wenn sie jetzt sagen in dem
in dem cimor herge-artikel sind auch
übrigens
finanzielle Motive von Norwegen erwähnt
die Norwegen vielleicht bewogen haben
damit zu machen und da finde ich es
schon ein interessanten eine
interessante Synchronizität sagen das
mal so dass Norwegen am Tag nach der
Explosion von Nord Streams eiserner
eigene Erdgaspipeline nach Osteuropa
aufgemacht hat das also einige Daten die
Herr Fleischer hier als Indizien Werte
was sagst du dazu
also ist gut dass sie ein kritischer
Nachfrage sind in allen Ehren dass es
genau richtig aber also sorry das ist
eine Verschwörungstheorie das stimmt
einfach nicht deshalb Joe Biden gesagt
es hat Victoria gesagt was ist daran die
Verschwörungstheorie hat Donald Trump
auch schon 2019 kurz vor der
Fertigstellung von Nord Stream 2
Sanktionen erlassen um und zwar hat er
das Gesetz zum Schutz von Europas
Energiesicherheit so hatte das genannt
die Firmen sanktioniert die an der
Fertigstellung von Nord Stream 2
mitwirken wollen sie das für sie so aus
als hätten die USA kein Interesse an der
Oder hätten als hätten die ihn Interesse
an der Fertigstellung von Nord Stream 2
gehabt Fragezeichen
Wladimir Putin der jeder jedes Jahr
Milliarden Euro verdient hat mit seinen
Erdgas Lieferungen nach Europa hatte
also in ein Interesse daran seine eigene
Pipeline in die Luft zu jagen da die mir
Putin der dafür bekannt ist dass er das
Information benutzt um den Westen zu
spalten und genau das passiert ja gerade
hier am Tisch zwischen uns
entschuldigung wo ist das Information
ich habe hier Fakten gelernt ich habe
gesagt Donald Trump hat diese Sanktionen
unterzeichnet ich habe gesagt die
obersten regierungsleute der USA haben
das gesagt wo ist da bitte
Desinformation gib ihnen recht dass die
Fakten die stimmen alle das ist richtig
aber nur weil die USA ein gewisses
wirtschaftliches Motiv haben gehen die
doch nicht hin und sprengen europäische
Infrastruktur und dann auch noch mit
Norwegen zusammen der US-Präsident sagt
es wird kein notsbeam 2 geben hat haben
sie sich doch nicht in die Luft gejagt
oder ich würde sagen wir müssen ein
bisschen rauszoomen und überlegen wer
hat hier wirklich die Fäden in der Hand
ich glaube das ist aber die diese diese
Begriffe also entschuldigung ich in der
zieht direkt kritisieren aber ich finde
glaube dieser Begriff der
verschwörungstheorischen auch ganz schön
überstrapaziert in der heutigen Zeit und
die glaube ich nicht alles sie haben
jetzt ganz klare Fakten genannt was
jemand gesagt hat jetzt muss man erstmal
unterscheiden auch zwischen Interessen
und der Aktion an sich ja also man es
gibt ja ganz ganz unterschiedliche
Interessen das heißt nicht automatisch
das ist die Person die gewisses
Interesse daran hat auch war so vor
allem auch von dem Hintergrund weil sie
gerade sagt ja ja bekanntesten
Informationen zu verbreiten es ist
leider immer so ein Krieg das Wort auf
allen Seiten sehr so Desinformationen
verbreitet wird und das und gerade auch
die USA
und einen Angriffskrieg und ich glaube
das können wir an dieser Stelle ganz
klar festhalten Herr Schaal wir wollen
sie sich in diese Diskussion einbringen
ich finde also aus Interessen und aus
Zitaten jetzt hier eine Handlung zu
rekonstruieren und das als Beweis
heranzuführen das ja ja sie haben gesagt
es ist eine eine starke Interessenlage
und das wird das das wären Fakten sind
keine Fakten Zitate genannt dass diese
Zitate gesagt wurden sind vielleicht
Fakten aber sie können nicht beweisen
oder herleiten dass diese diese Handlung
von den USA ausgehen ein ähm das weiß
ich auch zurück ich bin da ganz bei bei
den Kollegen Wachs zurück ins ins Reich
der Verschwörungstheorie verstehe ich
nicht der US-Präsident hat gesagt wenn
Russland in der Ukraine einmarschiert
wird es kein Nord Stream 2 geben und
jetzt sagen Sie ja das hat er doch nur
gesagt das ist ja gar kein Fakt das
verstehe ich nicht sie können doch nicht
sagen sie haben keinen einzigen sie
haben doch keinen man sagt was völlig an
den Hahn herbeigezogen
in der Pressekonferenz ist doch kein
Beweis für eine solche Meinung nicht
also bevor ich bevor ich vermute dass
Putin ein Interesse daran hätte seine
eigene Pipeline die er selber bezahlt
hat zu großen Teilen von denen er
jahrzehntelang großes Geschäft gemacht
hätte mit Europa selber in die Luft jagt
muss ich sagen sehe ich die
Interessenlage anhand der Dinge die in
den USA geäußert wurden eher in den USA
aber dann haben wir doch alle Interesse
daran dass es sofort aufgeklärt wird
damit diese ganze Information dieses
Misstrauen was dann haben sie recht hier
entsteht auf und ich bin bei
Bundesanwalt hat ja auch gesagt es gibt
keine Hinweise darauf die das Russland
dahinter steckt aber Aufklärung
funktioniert auch nur dann wenn wir
sozusagen die sie für dich zurecht
genannt haben immer gefallen sind
genauso sage ich mal in den
Grundmaterial dieser Aufklärung wieder
nach stammt irgendwie mit einfließen
lassen die vielleicht auch viele andere
Perspektive oder Aspekte also jetzt
sagen das eine dann also entweder wir
wollen aufklären und dann eine Antwort
haben oder wir haben von Anfang eine
Antwort dann brauchen wir aber nicht
mehr aufklär also dass ich ich will nur
ich sage nicht dass ich sage nur ich
sage nur dass wir uns glaube ich in
unseren aufklärungs Bemühungen die
Aufklärung funktioniert immer immer
besser ihr offener wird zumindest an so
eine Aufklärungsprozess rangehen die die
Sprengung dieser Pipeline fällt doch in
einen Zeitraum in dem klar war dass
Russland überhaupt kein verlässlicher
Energielieferant mehr für und sein kann
und überhaupt kein verlässlicher Partner
mehr sein kann also das heißt ähm rein
faktisch war doch schon diese Pipeline
längst geschlossen ja aber ist das jetzt
der Grund warum ein paar putiner sagt
gut dann eben nicht jetzt ja er spielt
mit unseren Ängsten er hat diese
Pipeline springen lassen um sie dann
sozusagen deaktiv Faktor zu versperren
und dann wird dadurch immer klar zu
machen das mit unserem Gaspreis hier die
Ängste in Europa geschildert haben uns
auseinander zu spalten das hat der Wachs
richtig gesagt den Westen zu zu
ängstigen überruhr-gaspreise damit
verloren also wenn Sie wenn Sie wo sind
jetzt ihre Fakten sozusagen wie sie das
untermauern das ist die Faktor war also
der hat gerade Aufklärung jetzt sagen
Sie es wahr sein das jetzt auf oder
haben wir jetzt die Fakten schon es muss
auch es muss aufgeklärt werden aber man
kann
entscheiden muss weiter aufgeklärt
werden Fall wird ja auch noch untersucht
aber die Zitate die Zitate du so
US-Präsidenten hinzulegen und sagen das
wäre jetzt jeder Beweis das kann ich
richtig sagen es muss aufgeklärt werden
das sagen alle hier im Tisch ich glaube
zumindest da herrscht Konsens jetzt
sprechen wir über ein phänomenes für
großes Aufsehen sorgt am Wochenende in
den vergangenen Tagen gab es immer
wieder Flugobjekte einige wurden
abgeschossen über den USA über Kanada
Alaska viele fragen dürfte das auf und
das ist ein Thema mit dem sie sich der
Fleischer intensiv beschäftigen ein
Thema bei dem manche sofort anfangen zur
Kirche und sagen ja hier jetzt reden wir
über pipip aus dem All aber sie fordern
dass wir uns diesen Thema endlich
ernsthaft nähern uns ernsthaft damit
auseinandersetzen so wie sie sagen das
andere Regierungen auch machen ihre Zeit
ihre Kamera genau das wurde auch nicht
nur ich sondern das fordern auch
Soziologen deutsche Soziologen und
Rechtswissenschaftler die sagen wir sind
überhaupt nicht auf die Möglichkeit vor
vorbereitet dass wir tatsächlich mal in
Kontakt kommen mit einer höher
entwickelten Spezies und so wie es
aussieht haben wir es mit so etwas zu
tun allerdings nicht aufgrund dieser
drei Objekte die in den USA jetzt
abgeschossen worden sind die zeigen eben
gerade nicht diese anomalen
Eigenschaften die uaps wie sie ja heißen
unidentifizierten an normalen Phänomenen
zugeschrieben werden und das sind
nämlich plötzliche Beschleunigung
hyperschallgeschwindigkeit ohne
Überschallknall geringe Beobachtbarkeit
transmedium Fortbewegung das heißt die
sind in der Lage aus dem Weltall in die
Atmosphäre und unter Wasser zu wechseln
und zurück ohne dass sie ihr
Flugverhalten ändern müssen allein das
ist sensationell und sie sind in der
Lage an der Stelle zu schweben ohne
sichtbare Auftrieb oder irgendwas und
sie verursachen zum Weinen auch
biologische Effekte bei Menschen so und
ähm man muss dazu sagen diese Objekte
die sind mit dem Wind getrieben deswegen
hat das hat das US Militär die auch
überhaupt abschießen können denn ich
muss sagen es wäre das allererste Mal
dass ich also ich habe noch nie davon
gehört dass es Militär es geschafft
hätte einen UFO wirklich abzuschießen es
gibt aber mehrere Fälle wo das versucht
worden ist und zwar im Iran 1976 da ist
ein Ufer über Teheran geschwebt Kampfjet
Pilot steigt auf wird dorthin geleitet
und in dem Moment wo er seine seitwinder
Rakete aufschaltet fallen seine
Bordinstrumente aus er muss umkehren und
verrichtete Dinge das wiederholt sich
zweimal es gibt einen anderen Fall noch
Brasilien mai 1986 13 stündige
sichtungswelle über den großen
Metropolen in Brasilien mindestens 21
UFOs
riesengroße UFOs teilweise werden von
Kampfjets gejagt die allerdings kein
Erfolg haben weil diese Objekte denen
ausweichen und denen dann folgen und
neben ihnen herfliegen laut den
freigegebenen militärunterlagen aus
Brasilien vom Militär und das Militär
denkt dass Intelligenz dahintersteckt
hat hinter diesen Objekten dasselbe in
Belgien 1989 90 bei drei Gelegenheiten
da gab es ja diese riesengroße
sichtungswelle mehr als 650 Sichtungen
mehr als
oder dreimal wurden F16 Kampfjets
gestartet einmal haben die schnelle
Änderungen in Tempo und Flughöhe
registriert aber sie haben es nicht
geschafft diese Dinger abzuschießen und
der bekannteste Fall ist ja erst 2004
von der Westküste der USA passiert
woaps um einen
Flugzeugträger rum geschwebt sind und da
haben sie es auch nicht geschafft und
diese uaps sind plötzlich wie aus einer
Gewehrkugel geschossen sind haben sich
von diesem Ort entfernt und haben sich
interessanterweise an dem Ort dann
eingefunden wo die Kampfjet erst
hinfliegen sollten das nennen die den
kerpoints den Einsatzpunkt von wo aus
dann weiteres Einsatz Geschehen geplant
wird und das ist auch interessant weil
man sich fragen muss woher wusste dass
die API wohin die Kampfjets dann fliegen
sollten also kurz in 28 Ländern auf der
Welt haben Militärs
UFO-Fälle dokumentiert schwerwiegende
UFO-Fälle teilweise es gibt in sieben
Ländern staatliche UFO
forschungsbehörden unter anderem in
unserem Nachbar und Frankreich da gibt
es das schon seit 1974 und in Amerika
ist Arrow jetzt gerade erst dazu
gekommen also Amerika ist sozusagen das
new kit on the block ja und warum machen
die das haben die nicht alle Untertassen
im Schrank oder warum werden warum
nehmen all diese Länder
UFOs so ernst und Deutschland nicht
warum gibt es das in Deutschland
angeblich nicht also ich fasse das mal
zusammen und ich muss zugeben mir fällt
der Ernährung an das Thema auch immer
noch schwer gleichzeitig denke ich wenn
man das Wunder der Welt begreift und
sieht was für ein Wunder Menschen sind
muss man vielleicht auch endlich mal den
Blick dafür öffnen und das hoffe ich
dass wir das hier an diesem Tisch auch
dementsprechend heute abend machen daher
jetzt die Frage an sie glauben also
wirklich das sozusagen eine Art erst
Kontakt bevorsteht oder dass wir den
schon längst erlebt haben und alle
anderen das Wissen und wir Deutschen
hoffen immer noch das ist doch irgendwie
nicht passiert oder wie kann
ich habe mit Kampfjet Piloten geredet
ich habe auch mit Geheimdienst dann
geredet aus Amerika unter anderem mit
begleitet das ehemaligen geheimen
ufo-forschungsprogramms und er sagt da
steckt definitiv eine Intelligenz
dahinter diesen Objekten die die dort
interessant finden also ich muss noch
sagen 90 Prozent von dem was gemeldet
wird ist wirklich Wetterballons und so
weiter und so fort aber die wirklich
interessanten Fälle das sind dann die
remaining die letzten verbleibenden zehn
bis fünf Prozent der Fälle die sich vor
allem eben in der Nähe von militärischen
Anlagen abspielen und was sich auch raus
kristallisiert immer mehr ist dass diese
Objekte vermehrt in der Nähe von
militärisch sensiblen atoman Anlagen
gesichtet werden so hat das Phänomen
überhaupt das angefangen das zieht sich
wie ein roter Faden durch die UFO
Geschichte muss man sagen und das ist
was was die Militärs und die
Geheimdienste sehr sehr ernst nehmen und
bei denen besteht kein Zweifel daran
dass es sich hier um irgendwelche
hochtechnologischen Objekte handelt also
mit einer Technologie wo wir nicht mal
entfernt dran kommen hinter denen
irgendeine Art von Intelligenz steckt
und da will ich jetzt nicht sagen das
ist die Aliens sind weil ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob die außerirdische
Hypothese die beste ist denn die Dinger
werden ja hier ständig gesehen irgendwo
ähm seit 2004 haben die haben allein die
Amerikaner mehr als 300 echte
interessante
UFO-Fälle registriert und zwar mit
mehreren Sensoren und so also nicht dass
da einer mal was gesehen hat haben sie
Angst davor
würde ich ja nicht machen also
also sie glauben das sind Phänomene mit
denen sollten wir uns auseinandersetzen
wenn wir Glück haben eines der jemand
gut mit uns ich glaube wir müssen uns
damit auseinandersetzen Soziologen sagen
wie gesagt katastrophale Folgen wenn
sich jetzt wirklich rausstellt also
nehmt mir lieber jetzt mal an das sind
werden jetzt wirklich außerirdische
Raumschiffe was ich nicht glaube die
jetzt abgeschossen worden sind aber
nehmen wir das mal an so die gehen jetzt
in kanadischen Territorium runter so ähm
angenommen ist steckt eine
hochentwickeltechnologie dahinter so ähm
wer hat denn da kein Interesse daran
sich dieser Technologie zu bemächtigen
um einen Vorteil zu bekommen denn die
Amerikaner untersuchen ganz offiziell
angebliche
UFO Trümmerteile
weiter als Deutschland und setzen sich
mit diesem Thema einfach auch mehr
auseinander
zum Lächeln bringt sie das in einer Art
panikmodus ist ihnen das schon zu viel
mehr also ich finde es erstmal eine gute
Nachricht das ist dafür zumindest mehr
seine Quelle gibt für diese Theorie ich
glaube das ist jetzt schon mal irgendwie
eine gute Sache nee also mich
verunsichert überhaupt nicht also ich
weiß natürlich nicht da tut es anyway
out there ich bin Kind der 90er ich habe
Akte X gesehen das hat mich immer sehr
sehr fasziniert auch wenn es natürlich
eine entertainisierung des Themas war
ich würde es mal so formulieren aus
meiner Perspektive würde ich sagen das
Weltall sie sagt gerade keine Ahnung wo
diese Wesen herkommen wenn es gewesen
sind was auch immer das Wetter ist auf
jeden Fall so groß dass es zumindest
vermessen wäre zu glauben wir sind die
einzigen intelligente Lebewesen in
diesem Universum optimal kommen in einem
Jahr in 100 Jahren weiß ich nicht
schwer
zu haben also entweder man glaubt quasi
das gleiche it hier auf der Matte steht
oder man sagt das gibt's einfach nicht
es scheint irgendwie keinen zwischendrin
zu geben auch heute auch auf Bild aber
Seite 1
UFO Krisenstab im Weißen Haus zu den
Ereignis am Wochenende da oder natürlich
ganz klar gesagt das ist jetzt nicht
anzunehmen dennoch wird das Thema ernst
genommen müssen wir uns da ein bisschen
mehr öffnen ja und das verkauft sich
natürlich waren sich gut ne das gehört
auch zu weit dazu über die werden
bestimmt noch ein Star mit ihrer
Geschichte auch wenn ich sie nicht
glaube aber das ist natürlich Teil des
Boulevard und das stimmt auch aber was
ich echt überhaupt nicht verstanden habe
ich glaube ich habe da entweder was
missverstanden oder Sie haben
Logikfehler sie haben gesagt dass das ja
gar nicht unbedingt UFOs sind also
Außerirdische sondern dass das
vielleicht auch eine touristische
Technik ist die da passiert die man aber
nicht richtig erklären kann wie war das
denn gemeint sie meinen nein es gibt ja
alle möglich ich sage die werden ja hier
ständig gesehen deswegen ist es ja eher
logisch anzunehmen dass die hier eine
Basis haben als dass die jedes Mal von
ihrem was weiß angeflogen kommen und
dann wieder zurück zurückfliegen oder
irgendwie sowas aber die Frage woher die
kommen das ist dann da über übernächste
Schritt das allererste was getan werden
muss das muss wissenschaftlich endlich
auf forscht werden das Stigma muss
beendet werden ich bin mehrfach in der
Bundespressekonferenz ausgelacht worden
weil ich diese Frage gestellt habe das
kann nicht sein wenn sie sich angucken
wie die internationale Situation ist und
es gibt in Deutschland einen Professor
an der Universität Würzburg der hat ein
internationales Forschungszentrum für
extraterrestrikt Professor Hakan Kajal
warum kriegt dieser Mann der offiziell
den Auftrag hat UFOs zu erforschen warum
kriegt der keine staatlichen
Fördergelder keine Ahnung okay
wann kommen wir endlich zur Berliner
Politik und drehen sich so ein bisschen
leicht weg oder nicht ganz hier ich bin
natürlich auch ich bin natürlich auch
großer Star Wars wenn und alleine schon
aufgrund des Vornamens kann ich mich mit
Luke Skywalker natürlich ja
identifizieren nein ganz im Ernst ich
beschäftige mich erstmal mit den Dingen
hier auf der Erde und den Dingen die wir
in Berlin anpacken wollen das sind eine
ganze Menge grundsätzlich
ist das natürlich richtig dass wir
erstmal wieder den Blick in den Himmel
richten müssen also das glaube ich schon
als menschheitsaufgabe wir waren auf dem
Mond das haben wir geschafft da waren
wir jetzt lange nicht gewesen wir haben
auch viele Planeten drumherum und den
Weltraum um uns herum zu erforschen das
ist eine menschheitsaufgabe die wir
nicht in Berlin auch vielleicht nicht in
Deutschland aber als Europäer auf jeden
Fall angehen können der macht er die e
seine ganze Menge Sachen ob die
Außerirdischen jetzt schon zu uns kommen
das sage ich erstmal zu bezweifeln oder
schon da sind das glaube ich auch ein
bisschen bei ihnen ähm
das muss wissenschaftlich das muss
geklärt werden erforscht werden so wie
die Sachen mit nordischen sage ich
wollte sagen ich bin ich treibt mich
auch auf Wissenschaftskonferenz nur um
die letzte Wissenschaftskonferenz hat
sich zum Beispiel gedreht darum wie
funktioniert der UFO Antrieb und so also
für diese Wissenschaftler die sich auf
hoher Ebene international oder rede ich
von wirklich hochrangigen
Wissenschaftlern mit der Frage
beschäftigen ist diese Frage ob sie gibt
oder nicht schon längst abgehakt die
Frage ist was
brauchen wir also brauchen wir mehr
Investitionen in Raumfahrttechnik
brauchen wir
jemanden der sich das Thema ist in der
Regierung annimmt ganz öffentliche
breite Debatte über die Folgen über
dieses ganze Thema ohne dass darüber
ständig gelacht wird ja also dieses
Lachen das ist schon sowas von
übergestrich ja wir müssen das Thema
endlich ernst nehmen zweitens wir
brauchen staatliche Forschungsgelder
oder zumindest muss möglich sein für
sowas wissenschaftliche Forschungsgeld
dazu kriegen die Wissenschaftler stehen
in den Startlöchern sie glauben nicht
mit wem ich manchmal telefoniere und ich
sagen ja aber ich kriege doch sowieso
keine Forschungsgelder dafür und das ist
ein Problem und ich denke in Würzburg an
der Universität mit dem Professor Kajal
hätte die Bundesregierung eine super
Mann also gleich eine Person
der einzige der das in Deutschland
offiziell als Wissenschaftler
untersuchen darf aber er hat keinen
Budget und wenn er kein Budget hat kann
das nicht untersuchen ernst sein dass
wir ernsthaft unser Steuergeld benutzen
sollen um sowas zu erforschen wenn wir
so viele echte Probleme haben die
Amerika wird es als die Bedrohung der
nationalen Sicherheit gesehen sie haben
gesehen dass gerade in Amerika los war
wieso sollten das so ein abgefahrenes
Thema sein das ist ein abgefahrenes
Thema gucken Sie doch mal auf die Straße
wir haben hier Lehrermangel überall wir
haben die Rentner die verarmt wir haben
sicher ist das Auto muss modernisiert
werden wir haben den Verbrenner aus 2035
also wir müssen so viel forschen das
kostet alles Steuergeld und Sie können
doch nicht ernsthaft dann sagen wir
nehmen eine oder zwei oder drei
Milliarden da weg nein nein
ich rede nicht von Milliarden aber sie
könnten schon mit einer Million extrem
viel ausrichten in der UFO-Forschung und
ich muss sagen es gebe ich Ihnen recht
es gibt natürlich auch ganz interessante
Probleme nicht zu knapp gerade im Moment
ja also die kümmern wir uns auch gleich
hier weil Viertel nach einer ganz kurzen
Pause bleiben Sie gerne bei uns bis
gleich
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren so für 8:15 Uhr wir haben viel
Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich sein
das ist doch völlig Realität fertig ich
finde unheimlich wichtig
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
total
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glückler
und der Bruder sich optisch ein bisschen
angepasst
haben wir haben zu viel starten und wir
uns gegenseitig in Berlin Mitte
Cappuccinos verkaufen das funktioniert
nicht dann ist alles essen als
freiheitlicher Mensch würde ich sagen
das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und umierungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar sein ich finde aber diese
gesamte Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch
ein bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt mit dem Gerät
[Musik]
da sind wir wieder zurück bei 8:15 Uhr
schön dass Sie bei uns sind es ist
Faschingszeit aber viele Kinder sollten
sich besser nicht mehr als Indianer
verkleiden werde ich alle Medien geht
auch die Geschichte aus Ober-Mörlen in
Hessen ja dort wird hart diskutiert dass
ein karnevalistisch schwarz angemalt hat
sie Herr Krischke ihnen geht vieles dazu
weit sie sagen das halten bei weiteres
Beispiel für rockness für Sie Teil einer
empörungskultur die auf viele Facetten
abzielt und die ihrer Ansicht nach auch
eher die Gesellschaft spaltet ihre Zeit
ja ich glaube dass sie die sogenannte
walkenes oder alles was wir darunter
subsumieren und auch die
Identitätspolitik die mit reinspielt
unterm Strich unsere Freiheit gefährdet
ich sehe aber trotzdem eine ganze Reihe
positive Entwicklung ins auch wenn wir
gerade wieder diskutieren über einen
blackfacing Vorwurf gegenüber eines
Karnevalisten der von Boris rein
empfangen wurde es gab eine vergangenen
Woche drei interessante Meldungen in dem
Zusammenhang die Surf die Krone besser
die Hamilton beispielsweise weigert sich
weiter für ihren Verband anzutreten wenn
dieser die Planken Transgender
Regelungen umsetzt wonach auch
biologische Männer in der
frauenkategorie antreten dürfen wir
hatten einen Musiker Helge Schneider bei
einem Talkshow Auftritt vergangene Woche
der den Vorwurf der kulturellen
aneigungen Musik kommentierte mit das
interessiert mich einen Scheißdreck
außerdem zeigt eine jüngste Umfrage von
intertest die mehr im Auftrag von des
WDR das ist ein Großteil oder der größte
Teil der Menschen sich nicht fürs
Gendern interessiert und auch wir müssen
da aktuell mit und haben diese Woche von
sie zu einem Buch veröffentlicht mit dem
Thema die walkeness Illusion denn
Political Correctness die Freiheit
gefährdet und ich hoffe dass unser Buch
aber genauso auch die Vorkommnisse in
der vergangenen Woche ein bisschen zu
einer Konter Revolution in dem ganzen
einladen einige Beispiele aufgezählt wo
sehen sie in welchem Aspekt die Freiheit
besonders gefährdet an wo fühlen sie
sich in ihrer Freiheit eingeschrieben
ich persönlich ich persönlich für mich
aktuell noch nicht in meiner Freiheit
eingeschränkt ich glaube man muss auch
differenzieren wir haben auch lange über
den Untertitel wenn political correkt
ist die Freiheit gefährdet diskutiert
wir sagen ja aktuell nicht das ist quasi
dass wir jetzt in einem unfreien
Gesellschaft leben aber es gibt
Tendenzen wo man zumindest sieht das
dass diese Tendenzen gegen eher die
freiheitliche aufgeklärte Gesellschaft
sich richten und erkennen wir unter
anderem auch darin dass das diese diese
diese wirkungste Debatte also ich stehe
ja nicht morgens auf und sage ja heute
beschäftigt mich wieder mit dem Thema
dass diese Worte von mir quasi
funktioniert oder für uns inszenieren
alle möglichen Bereich unsere
Gesellschaft vor
Natur beispielsweise in den Niederlanden
wurde jetzt kürzlich ein Stück abgesagt
weil nur Männer in diesem Stück spielen
sollten laut Samuel Becker das Stück
geschrieben hat genau wir haben Themen
wieder unternehmerischen Freiheit
beispielsweise wo irgendwelche
diversitybeauftragten den ganzen Laden
durcheinander würfeln und irgendwie
Unruhe reinbringen und wir haben eben
auch nicht zuletzt hat mir auch nicht
vergessen das ist ein bisschen auch ihr
Thema wir hatten vor Silvester den 29
seitigen sprachkatalog an die Berliner
Polizei die jetzt wirklich andere
Probleme hat als er sich jetzt 29 Seiten
damit auseinandersetzen was du willst
einfach sagen was nicht
vor 50 Jahren noch normalerweise sagen
wir jetzt nicht mehr die Menschheit muss
ich halt auch weiterentwickeln denken
sie da irgendwelche Gefahren ja
natürlich also Weiterentwicklung das ist
natürlich weiterentwickelt ja klar muss
ich alles weiterentwickeln und da darf
man auch keine klappen haben die Dinge
entwickeln sich weiter aber es muss eben
natürlich Weiterentwicklung aus der
Gesellschaft heraus für die Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft sein und wenn das was Sie
beschrieben haben lieber Krischke das
sind ja oft Sachen die werden von der
kleinen Minderheit eigentlich der großen
Mehrheit der Gesellschaft aufgezwungen
und gehen eigentlich an den Problemen
der Menschen vor Ort vorbei sie sagen
richtig die bin ja Polizisten haben hier
ein richtig harten Job der ist hier
richtig viel zu tun in dieser Stadt
nicht nur in der Silvesternacht sondern
Tag für Tag jede Nacht jeden Tag auch
die Rettungskräfte von Feuerwehr und
Sanitär ja und wir stehen an deren Seite
und wenn sie nicht bevormunden mit
Sprachregelungen oder mit dem
Antidiskriminierungsgesetz dass sie
nachweisen müssen dass sie die
beweislands haben dass sie nicht
diskriminiert haben ja wir müssen doch
erstmal Vorurteil frei in dem rangehen
blackfazit bei einer Karnevalsparty
hätten sie das Fisch falsch halten Sie
das für okay Gendern Ja oder Nein lassen
sie uns konkreten also das Thema das
Thema Gendern ist eins wo ich sagen muss
Werder wer denn so sprechen möchte der
kann so sprechen aber er muss sich
bewusst sein dass er an der Mehrheit der
Menschen in diesem Land einfach vorbei
redet und da wo Gendern sozusagen aus
vom Staat herauskommt also da wo die
Verwaltungsbehörden geänderte Briefe
schreiben da wohl Universitäten Schüler
und Studenten dazu verpflichten zu
Gendern in ihren Abschlussarbeiten und
sonst notenabzüge androhen da geht das
nicht und blackfacing das Beispiel das
jetzt gerade für großen Aufruhr sorgt
aus Hessen das für sie okay ja das muss
man sich das muss man sich anschauen
wieder wie das im Einzelfall gemacht
wird also wenn sich jetzt jemand auf dem
Foto festgehalten
wurde ich sag jetzt mal meins wäre es
nicht ähm das muss man für sich selbst
entscheiden ob man ob man so rumlaufen
will und ob man damit nicht
möglicherweise Gefühle von anderen
Menschen verletzt ähm ich glaube ein
bisschen mehr Sensibilität bei vielen
Sachen würden uns gut tun also das ist
für andere Menschen unangenehm sein kann
das Geschehen sie zu Herr Fleischer und
sie wo sehen sie sehen sie Gefahren sie
leben in Spanien ist das vielleicht auch
eine Diskussion die man mit Blick von
außen wie in Deutschland besonders
intensiv führen nein also es wird auch
in der spanischen Sprache versucht zu
Gendern was
schwerer möglich ist als im Deutschen
ich wollte dazu noch sagen
ich habe ja Sprachen studiert und mir
fällt da kein Vorteil auf
JournalistInnen
Journalistinnen und Journalisten und so
weiter und so fort also das ist meine
persönliche Meinung dazu und ich habe
mit großem Interesse dem
Psychotherapeuten Bonelli gelauscht der
hier neulich zu Gast war der gesagt hat
dass die wokners sozusagen der die
letzte Äußerung eines Narzissmus werden
moralischen Narzissmus das fand ich sehr
treffend also sozusagen als ein Symptome
einer Gesellschaft mit der irgendwas
nicht stimmt ja also das
erscheint mir ziemlich interessant
werden unsere Gesellschaft so ein
bisschen ihre These sie sagen der geht
auch eine Gefahr von aus da geht davon
die Gefahr aus dass er immer mehr wir
uns Spalten also ich glaube das wird zum
nächsten Mal sehen ist das eigentlich
ich fast keine dieser Maßnahmen den
gewünschten Effekt hatte den sie
eigentlich hätte haben sollen also weder
sind jetzt die Straßen in Berlin
sicherer doch so einen Katalog noch
haben wir uns besonders beliebt gemacht
im Ausland mit der Aktion in Qatar die
auch ein bisschen so ein rohrkrippierer
war und was mich halt vor allem auch
stört das ist oft so sind dann immer so
Bekenntnisse ab dem gar keine Taten
folgen aber man man stellt sich dann
beispielsweise als besonders gutes
Unternehmen da an dem man jetzt
irgendwie eine Regenbogenflagge vor die
Tür stellt und dann guckt man irgendwie
das Unternehmen rein da steht man fest
aha da werden jetzt schon wieder
irgendwie so und so viel Jobs
abgebrochen weil da vielleicht um uns
irgendwelchen Investoren rechts zu
machen also ich glaube das das Problem
dass ich mit dieser ganzen Sache habe es
wirklich dieses dass wir uns da dass wir
über Themen diskutieren die eigentlich
für den Großteil der Menschen überhaupt
gar nicht relevant sind und da würde ich
gerne zurück ich würde auch gerne zurück
dahin dass ich linke Parteien wieder um
soziale Fragen kümmern und nicht um die
Frage wie ich eine Frage formulieren
muss damit sich vermeintlich niemand
verletzt fühlt sich beides kann man sich
nicht um die Inhalte kümmern Viktor und
dennoch um die Form der Darstellung das
ganze ist wie ein Pendel glaube ich das
hin und her schwingt und im Moment sind
wir an dem Punkt das haben Sie auch
schon gesagt wo das Panel sozusagen am
weitesten nach außen schlägt und wir
Herr Christel da stimme Ihnen zu
wirklich Felge Absurditäten haben aber
Patricia und deine Frage zu beantworten
ob beides geht ich weiß es nicht was ist
denn zum Beispiel mit Dreadlocks ja es
wird jetzt gesagt weiße Leute sollen
keine Dreadlocks mehr haben sie haben
das alle mitgekriegt da wurde eine weiße
Sängerin die auf einem Walken Festival
auftreten sollte Last Minute
rausgeschmissen weil sie Dreadlocks
hatte und dann wurde gesagt dass es
jetzt kulturelle Aneignung dann hat die
aber gesagt nein nein meine Vorfahren
sind Wikinger und die hatten auch
Dreadlocks und deswegen ist es aber doch
wieder in Ordnung ja und jetzt also es
passt hinten und vorne nicht wissen was
ich meine wo ist er gerade für sie der
Gradmesser dass man sagt das ist eine
gesellschaftliche Weiterentwicklung weil
wir uns weiterentwickeln und wo beginnt
für sie der Punkt dass sie sagen das
wird irgendwie absurd das verlieren wir
eventuell auch Menschen können Sie diese
diesen Punkt irgendwo machen also ich
glaube man kann es man kann es an der
Historie auch klar klar festmachen
irgendwie beispielsweise Frauenwahlrecht
ja das ist natürlich absoluter
Fortschritt ja jetzt aber quasi überall
Sexismus zu wittern ist es vielleicht
halt nicht oder wenn man sagt man man
ist Sexismus gewittert also diese
Diskussion die werden teilweise führen
über irgendwelche bikini-werbungen oder
sogar die gehen mir einfach echt ein
Stück zu weit und da wird dann auch
irgendwie auch auf Frauen im jetzt bin
ich natürlich der Frauenbeauftragte und
schwierig irgendwie finden Geschlecht zu
sprechen nämlich angehöre aber da wird
dann Frauen dann auch so ein bisschen
irgendwie einfach das Recht genommen
irgendwie sich selber auch irgendwie
sich selber zu entscheiden
fotografieren oder was mache ich oder
schminke ich mich oder schminke ich
nicht oder oder bleibe ich lieber zu
Hause oder gehe ich lieber arbeiten ich
liebe Karriere wenn ich lieber
Hausfrauen Mutter ich finde das sind
doch dann muss doch allen Lebens
Entwürfen die die wir so haben doch die
Möglichkeit geben dass sich diese Lebens
Entwürfe einigermaßen ja dann frei
bewegen können und auch frei leben
können das ist doch lieber daran
arbeiten
bei dem jetzt schon irgendwas
einzuschränken oder bei denen schon
wieder irgendwas einzuschränken weil das
jetzt wiederum nicht irgendeinem
Zeitgeist und dann vermeintlichen
Zeitgeist entspricht was ist denn mit
der freien Entfaltung der Persönlichkeit
wieso darf ich denn meine Haare nicht
als Zopf machen oder aber dann dürfen
sie auch nicht Blackface essen also das
ist dann werde Moral ins Bett legt was
mit Doppelmoral aus frei ich will
einfach meine Persönlichkeit frei
entfalten und wenn ich der Meinung bin
ich muss mit dem Rock rumlennen Rennen
und mit einem was weiß ich
regenschirmhut oder sowas warum denn
nicht gern machen das müssen Sie gar
nicht sie müssen keinen Rock der
beruhigen sie
dürfen aber
ich rate bei diesen ganzen Thema zu
etwas mehr Gelassenheit ja und
vielleicht in die Diskussion nicht immer
dem anderen immer dass das schlechteste
zu unterstellen also nicht jemandem der
jetzt nicht gender zu unterstellen dass
er irgendwie Frauen überhaupt nicht mit
meint oder
dritte Geschlechter nicht anerkennt oder
sowas das ist wirklich ein bisschen mehr
Gelassenheit ein bisschen respektvoll
miteinander dann kommen alle weiter aber
was ist denn damit der CDU und der
Frauenquote dass da so hin und her
gerungen wurde bis Mann Ergebnis da war
ja da haben wir diskutiert in der Partei
und der Partei hat eine Entscheidung
getroffen und die geht jetzt alle
drin ihrer Partei schauen wir uns einmal
diese Karte an man sieht hier viel
schwarz dann sieht man ein grünen ja
grünes Zentrum und dann sieht man hier
noch mal schwarz und das das ist ihr
Erfolg kann man sagen das ist ihr voll
wären sie das geschafft Berlin Mitte
erscheinen ja den Wahlkreis in Berlin
Mitte haben wir tatsächlich gewonnen für
die CDU durfte ich hier repräsentieren
durch die antreten für meine Partei und
es ist natürlich ein toller ein großer
Erfolg dass wir zwei Innenstadtbezirk
also auch im Wedding kann man arbeitet
gewonnen und hier unten sozusagen den
hauptstand Bezirk zwischen Brandenburger
Tor Alexanderplatz
den haben wir gewonnen ja ein ein Bezirk
der der im Herz der DDR sozusagen ist
und eine lange Zeit von der Linken und
ihren Nachfolgern gewonnen wurde und das
ist ähm ein schöner Erfolg der aber auch
zeigt insgesamt hat Berlin den wechselt
sie haben das gesehen fast keine fast
keine roten Wahlkreise mehr sein die
meisten sind hier wirklich an die Union
gegangen Berlin
Wechsel und es ist für uns natürlich ein
großer Vertrauensvorschuss von den
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern dass sie uns
zutrauen die Stadt ein Stück weit wieder
ins Funktionieren zu bringen
sogar die Mehrheit der SPD Wähler
wünscht sich eine CDU geführte Regierung
jetzt dabei und ich denke wir werden in
den nächsten Wochen sondieren mit den
Parteien und dann gemeinsam eine
Regierung bilden können
dennoch sie geben sich jetzt
optimistisch könnte es auch sein dass
die alte Koalition einfach weitermacht
also wenn wir hier jetzt mal konkret sie
sagen wir kriegen den Regierungsauftrag
mit wie machen sie das denn dann mit der
SPD oder mit den Grünen oder ist fast eh
schon egal weil fast schon das gleiche
also wir haben ja wir haben ja
beschlossen dass wir mit beiden Parteien
sondieren wollen das findet jetzt das
schauen wir mal also wir wollen wir
wollen mit dem regieren mit dem wir
diese Stadt nach vorne bringen können
das gerne in der Verkehrspolitik
vielleicht mit der SPD etwas leichter
gehen es kann aber bei dem Thema
Modernisierung der Verwaltung vielleicht
auch mit den Grünen dann spannendes
Projekt werden wir gehen in diese
Gespräche sehr offen herein wir
erreichen die Hand den beiden
platzierten die ja zeitgleich durch Ziel
gekommen sind wenn man das so will aber
mit deutlichem Abstand hinter uns liegen
150.000 Berlinerinnen und Berliner haben
uns mehr ihre Stimme gegeben als den
Band aber auch so ein bisschen so wir
nehmen den den wir kriegen können wie
wollen Sie denen das denn geschmackhaft
machen was bieten sie nein wir nehmen
nicht den den wir kriegen können sondern
wir nehmen den mit dem wir unser
Programm in weiten Teilen oder am besten
umsetzen können und mit dem wir einen
gemeinsamen Zukunft schaffen können wir
diese Stadt die Probleme liegen auf der
Hand manchmal auch auf der Straße und
die wollen wir angehen und wer damit den
Weg mit uns gehen will mit dem sind wir
bereit da ernsthaft drüber zu reden wo
sehen Sie die großen Unterschiede
zwischen Rot und Grün in Berlin zwischen
rot und Grünen habe ich ja eben gesagt
also das Thema der Verkehrspolitik das
ist bei den das ist bei den Grünen wird
das sicherlich eine ganz großes
verhandlungsthema über das war sprechen
müssen auch das Thema der Innenpolitik
ist sicherlich mit der SPD leichter zu
gestalten aber
sie sehen das ja auch die Grünen haben
hier viele Wahlkreise gewonnen das heißt
es ist ja immer eine zeigt eine
Verwurzelung in der Stadtgesellschaft
deswegen muss man das ernst nehmen und
auch mit den Grünen offen reden reden
gleichzeitig sehen wir ja das ist auch
in anderen Bundesländern ist bereits
Regierungen gab die trotzdem die Wahl
vorher nicht gewonnen haben nur mehrere
Schweiz dann trotzdem möglich könnte man
auch sagen na ja so ist es eben auch
manchmal
machen halt in dem Fall in Berlin die
weiter
ja es gibt ja es gibt natürlich keine
Verpflichtung der der SPD jetzt zu sagen
okay wir geben das sozusagen den Krone
an die an die CDU weiter aber ich finde
also 10% ist schon der Ansage und ich
finde es erstmal richtig dass du auch
Sondierungsgespräche geführt werden wir
haben selbst eine Redaktion
verschiedenste Meinungen wie es
weitergehen könnte also ich tippe auf
schwarz rot tatsächlich weil ich glaube
dass die SPD und die CDU doch noch als
sage ich mal Parteien eher der Mitte
nach dem ersten vielleicht zusammen
finden jetzt die Grünen ähm mit der CDU
beispielsweise aber klar es gibt
natürlich auch diese diese Konstellation
also Hendrik Wüsten beispielsweise
also ich bin wirklich wirklich sehr
gespannt was da am Ende bei rumkommt
wenn ich eine kleine Anmerkung machen
darf ich fand die nur eine porte sehr
sehr schön also ich kann mich erinnern
wie damals bei Armin Laschet die SPD
ihn als schlechten Wahl Verlierer
bezeichnet hat wegen einem Prozentpunkt
ungefähr Unterschied jetzt gewinnen Sie
mit zehn Prozentpunkte und Frau esken
sagt offiziell so jetzt müssen wir jetzt
erstmal analysieren wo ich sage was
müssen sie dann noch analysieren also
egal was am Ende bei rumkommt ich weiß
nicht ob es ein klares Signal war das
ein bisschen starkes Signal und klar ist
ein ganz klassisches weiter so kann es
nicht geben also ich glaube es wäre
schon ein bisschen auch ich glaube der
andere mit sich auch verarscht vorkommen
jetzt quasi die Regierung mit dem
Personal dass sie aktuell hat jetzt
einfach so weiter macht das wäre nichts
gewesen bitte die SPD auch so ein
bisschen ihre Stammwählerschaft aus den
Augen verloren hat man das jetzt in der
Hauptstadt gesehen eine Arbeiter
beispielsweise die SPD die eigentlich
während des hier gerade gesagt na ja ob
wir es mit den Grünen mit der SPD da
gibt's ja nuancenverkehrspolitik
vielleicht ein großer Punkt aber sonst
unterscheidet sich der teilweise gar
nicht mehr so
er hat gesagt die SPD ist eigentlich
eine Volkspartei und hat sich ein Nullen
lassen von irgendeiner walkenes an der
Mehrheit vorbei es wird Politik an der
Mehrheit vorbei gemacht die haben
Wahlkampf an der Mehrheit vorbeigebracht
und sie haben Berlin an der Mehrheit
vorbei regiert und deswegen ist das was
der Schal sagt richtig dass die Mehrheit
hier sich gewünscht hat dass ein Wechsel
stattfindet hier war eine wahlklatsche
und die jetzt einfach zu ignorieren und
zu tun als wäre diese komische
dreier-koalition wiedergegeben
aber als wäre sie bestätigt worden ist
falsch und es wäre demokratisch legitim
da jetzt weiter zu machen aber wäre es
wirklich okay ich glaube nicht gesagt
zweites für möglich für wahrscheinlich
SPD und CDU zusammen glaubst du Viktor
dass sich damit die SPD so ein bisschen
wieder rehabilitieren könnte wenn sie
jetzt in einer Regierung in Berlin geht
mit der CDU sich dann auch wieder auf
diese Seiten zu besinnen eine starke SPD
ist glaube ich für dieses Land und auch
für Berlin total wichtig das muss es
geben es muss eine Partei geben die die
Arbeiter sie haben selbst gesagt
repräsentiert aber das kann nur
passieren wenn sie sich komplett neu
erfindet ich wünsche Ihnen dass Sie mit
denen eine Koalition gehen ich glaube
das kriegen sie nicht hin übrigens ich
glaube es wird einen ähm ja muss ich
leider sagen ja ich glaube die werden zu
dritt weiter regieren leider so schade
das ist aber ich wünsche der SPD auch
von Herzen dass Sie sich neu erfinden
kann und personell auch mal erfinden und
wir wissen alle was das bedeutet ein
Ersatz für Franziska gefallen das müssen
wir mal schauen also wir sind in den
nächsten Jahren ist jedes Jahr in Berlin
eine Wahl also
im nächsten Jahr findet Europawahl statt
im Jahr danach die Bundestagswahl und im
Jahr danach weil das ja eine
Wiederholungswahl war die nächste Berlin
mal also wenn Rot-Rot-Grün hier
tatsächlich in den nächsten drei Jahren
noch mal dieses Experiment sage ich
jetzt mal wagen will diese
experimentierkoalition die in den
letzten Jahren schon an vielen Stellen
Flickschusterei betrieben hat dann
blicke ich dem sehr entspannt entgegen
vielleicht gibt es ja auch noch
geschrieben einen kleinen Joker Kevin
Kühnert Joker der SPD glaubst du dass
das etwas bringen kann
also der ist ein griffiger Typ wir
kennen ihn alle ähm er hat nie so
richtig gearbeitet außer meinem
Callcenter deswegen haben glaube ich
viele Arbeiter in der SPD so gewisse
Störgeräusche mit ihm aber besser als
Franziska giffer ist er alle mal ich
glaube auch wenn der in ihrem Wahlkreis
angetreten hätte dann
quasi perfekt wenn man jetzt dann noch
Kevin Kinder sind
also Wahlbetrug von sowas würde ich
niemals sprechen ist nicht meine
Wortwahl
wer die Mehrheit der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger hinter sich hat keine Regierung
und natürlich geht es darum um die
Mehrheit im Parlament das weiß ich schon
Rot-Rot-Grün hat da rechnerisch noch
eine Mehrheit aber ich glaube wenn man
jetzt so die Nachfrage fragen Sie auch
anschaut 65% der Berlinerinnen und
Berliner wünschen sich eine Regierung
Unterführung der CDU auch die Mehrheit
der SPD Wähler erkennt das an und sie
haben es ja richtig gesagt also 10 %
sind eine Hausnummer und das sehen auch
die Leute draußen auf der Straße so ich
empfehle den Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von SPD und Grünen nächstes Wochenende
das zu tun was sie letztes Wochenende
auch getan haben ihren Infostand zu
packen sich in die Fußgängerzone zu
stellen und mit den Menschen darüber zu
reden glaube wenn Sie mehr glauben wenn
sie was sie glauben wer diese Stadt
regieren soll ich glaube sie werden sehr
eindeutige Antwort bekommen
sie
30 Jahren auf den Weg gemacht nach
Mallorca gehören das Ganze aus der Ferne
beobachten schütteln sie da so ein
bisschen den Kopf was gerade in der
Hauptstadt passiert da kommt erst die
Wiederholung von der Wahl denn wir
erinnern uns da ging dann irgendwelche
Wahlzettel verloren auf dem Fahrrad
musste man noch mal neue besorgen jetzt
also die Wiederholung und jetzt sagt
aber die alte Koalition ja moment mal
eigentlich können wir jetzt weitermachen
wie bisher sind sie da fast froh
ausgewandert zu sein und ich habe gehört
dass das was in der Hauptstadt passiert
in der Politik in dass das sozusagen die
das Zukunft die zukunftsproduktion von
dem ist was dann für den Rest des Landes
auch noch zutrifft und dann muss ich
sagen bitte nicht ja also bitte machen
Sie anständige Politik ja
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen also
immerhin haben sie es jetzt geschafft
offenbar die zweite Wahl ordentlich zu
organisieren das ist auch schon was 450
oder die Hammer gefunden wurden halt
nicht ganz also gibt's nur ein paar
kleine Haken aber jetzt mal ernsthaft
gab es für sie bestimmte Gründe
auszuwandern in Deutschland zu verlassen
immer wieder sitzen wir hier in dieser
Sendung und kritisieren viele wir
schauen den Politikern da auch ganz
genau auf die Finger gab es bei ihnen
irgendeinen bestimmten Grund wo sie
sagten also ich muss jetzt wirklich
woanders leben ja es gab mehrere Gründe
also der persönliche ist natürlich auch
ich habe ja Dolmetscher studiert und
wissen Sie wenn Sie eine Weile im
Ausland waren und dann kommen sie wieder
zurück nach Deutschland und dann sehen
Sie immer wieder diese selben also ich
meine das ist ja hier eine ziemlich
deutsche Runde ja es sind wir reden über
walkness und und über Hundekacke Attacke
also das sind so typisch deutsche Themen
ja die Deutschen sind die Deutschen sind
Weltmeister im aufregen ja und wissen
Sie warum es keine WM im in empörungs-wm
gibt weil die Deutschen immer die
Weltmeister werden also und das ist eben
so ein Ding da wünscht man sich dann
eben auch mal woanders hin und abgesehen
davon ist das Wetter in Friede und
Sonnenschein aber ich glaube in Spanien
in talkshop da schreibt man sich doch an
ohne Ende oder da ist ja nicht so dass
er durch Frieden und Freude ja das ja
das stimmt aber das gehört auch
irgendwie zum Temperament und die sind
danach ganz fröhlich wieder also ja das
Temperament bei uns ist auch noch
fröhlich sind
[Gelächter]
Spanien auswandern um ein bisschen
verwirrt teilweise auf dieser Hauptstadt
zu gucken also ich bin ja kein Berliner
ich bin ja Münchner und muss reicht auch
vier Stunden sich im ICE zu setzen damit
zu fahren von München mal zu beobachten
was in Berlin so abgeht um sich schon
auch durchaus zu wundern also auch die
Verwundung gibt es auch eine näheren
Umgebung trotzdem mehr Fleisch ich bin
auch Dolmetscher und Patricia weiß dass
ich habe hier für Bild auch schon sehr
viel dolmetscht den ganzen Prozess am
Behörde Johnny Depp und so und ich kenne
das alles ich habe auch mal in Spanien
gewohnt in Katalonien so wie sie aber
ich von trotzdem immer noch sehr gerne
in Deutschland
übrigens mehr über die Aliens erfahren
will die vielleicht schon alle unter uns
sind sie im Buch darüber geschrieben
TV extra Magazin TV einmal noch also
wenn sie da noch mal in die Recherche
einsteigen wollen hier ist die Website
ganz herzlich fürs zuschauen ich bedanke
mich bei meiner Runde machen sie es gut
bis dann
[Musik]